news this time from Russia where an
American reporter has been arrested and
accused of Espionage Russian security
officials claim that Evan gerskovic he
works for the Wall Street Journal was
trying to obtain classified information
the spokesman for President Putin said
he was caught red-handed those are his
words collecting information about the
Russian military complex he's accused of
Espionage that carries a 20-year
sentence the 31 year old reporter has
been working for the Wall Street Journal
in Moscow since January 2022 but he had
previous experience reporting from
Russia in a statement Wall Street
Journal vehemently denies the
allegations and seeks his immediate
release